destroys which is getting 92 seconds
he's gonna Super Saiyan yes yeah die
yeah good good today we're playing
pigeon simulator very nice survival mode
or sandbox mode if Sun I don't know
sure let's do sandbox mode oh my god I'm
pigeon wow this is so realistic feeling
lost I always do even as a pigeon oh I
got people and I'm coming right for them
oh oh my god I'm
oh god I can't stop oh god I'm so up
animal abuse hey ah what is wrong with
you riho nord vpm special christmas
offer for the percy you don't know nor
VPN is a VPN what it makes it so that
you can securely connect to anywhere
around the world you can bypass any sort
of regional block basically it's super
fast and if I want to watch Netflix
America I just click poof America and
bing bang bong I am in you can even
bypass the Great Wall of China you may
have heard news there were some security
issues with Nord VPN nothing was stolen
your data is safe don't worry it was
massively overblown a new story being
massively overblown what they are taking
it very seriously still and improving
security even further and they are
moving to 100% owned servers which will
make them the first VPN with 100% owned
servers because of regardless of the
branding most VPN servers are from a
third party okay I feel like I have to
address that I use nor VP on every
single day it's fast it's reliable it's
safe
it helped me access epicness and right
now we have a special offer where you
can save 81 percent and you get two
extra gift bonus gift you get four extra
month on Nord VPN and Nord pass for free
Nord pass for Freight which is worth
almost $200 what nor pass is a website
we can store all your passwords safely
and securely on one spot gets saved for
passwords and access them easily epic
that's a good deal it's a legitimately
good deal just go to no VPN that comma
sighs PewDiePie enter code PewDiePie
that's it on with the video
you need the food ok nice
it's on fire how how did that happen bro
you all right let me just grab his stick
sorry thank you I need to stick oh I'm
flying now I need a stick for a nest
land successful landing nice all right
so how do I pick stuff up no that's
flying clearly it's flying excuse me
gentlemen
thank you can a pigeon freaking man ooh
ooh you look a little tense there boy
let me give you a massage that's right
you like that Oh oh yes you do let me
struggle up by the rock yeah that's
right you like that wait I can puke on
them oh sorry about that sorry about
that bro let me fly away hey guys Oh
blood oh god this is bad
a flight like Angel wow this game you
can fly so high wow I feel like a bird
flying across universe I love it oh oh
let me this thank you mmm this is what
birds do they fit Jase si launched in
space this is what birds do they feed
each other mouth to mouth here you go
bro bro I got you bro so hungry I'm
flying so high like it Oh why do they
hit the bird who punches a bird come on
bro don't punch me don't push me bro
come on gimme share the snack Jesus
Christ you'll pay for this you'll pay
for this mark my word Hey look at that
it works delicious nutrients I never
realized this how much society
discriminates against a bird watch this
hahahahaha God of this mother flipping
mushrooms bro damn oh yeah delicious
nutrients well what is this
whoa are you serious
1945 Nagasaki colorized I'm so sorry
oh god I'm starving any teen fast no
stamina I don't need to know how to poop
right now game alright we're good we're
gonna limp don't cry children I'm going
to live no oh my god the see over racism
killed me here we go here we go
Oh Oh stinky
I made a poopie you love burn what to do
a fire hide behind table remember kids
so what's the goal of this game again
alright I think I'm ready for the main
game which i think is you have oh why
yes toast alright as ever nest we grab
sticks just gotta stick the landing here
we go absolutely stunning
oh god I'm starving any teen fast no
stamina I don't need to know how to poop
right now game ever got nothing in the
movie oh my god Society I have to murder
them I'm sorry I didn't want to do it i
watch this
i watch this yeah got him wait what's
that what what the hell is that
what the hell is that yeah let me ride
the forklift if I can try the fort I am
under a four clip stop stop stop I'm
getting cyberbully oh oh dribble count
dropout yeah
yes replenish chef yes delicious got him
oh oh he's breaking it down hey look big
BP eh
alright so where do I go oh god where's
my nest there it is okay I got one nice
the more the more you poop the more
hungry you are the more you know gamers
now you know I describe this nice the
nest is full the nest is complete where
my child where is my child I can lay
eggs now keep your eggs warm how God am
I supposed to do everything did you guys
know that there's no baby pigeons have
you ever seen a baby pigeons you know
why because they're government spies by
Barack Obama either there get some food
and puke over them what the hell is this
kinky game getting good at this game I'm
not gonna lie all right I think I have
enough to feed my children they clearly
don't deserve it but I gotta do it I
just ate a barrel I ate a frickin barrel
dude ten out of ten good game alright
everyone will get puked on no no there
we go enjoy the purple puke are you
happy now I feel like it's not doing
anything
just eat just eat it
stop stop just eat I'm trying
stop he's having seizure stop it I know
I shouldn't have eaten the freaking
barrel ah oh god it started again it's
kicking in and I'm gonna starve now help
me sir sir kind sir help me Hey ah oh my
gosh are you kidding me get up I'm gonna
starve I'm gonna start I'm free I'm free
at last at last yes No
good night girl I see you tomorrow can I
Drive one of the cars so maybe that
could be cool or there's a freaking
giant football can I score can I score
come on pigeon Hey Oh God
they're playing rough looks like pigeon
one human zero come on come on I can do
this this is me playing football in
school basically come on come on come on
damn it
don't hit me Oh God I know why this game
is randomly telling me how to poop yes
yes yes yes Oh oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I
can hold the book I can hold I'm holding
the ball we're going for the score he's
gonna score yeah damn it he's got the
ball
Phyllis Michele Berg it's about to score
his first goal in the whole world can he
do it yes he can and again and again
it's not a goat are they paying tribute
to goat simulator wait I can talk to go
I got a quest okay Jay says destroy when
she's getting ninety two seconds
he's gonna Super Saiyan yes yes die yes
by pigeon police cars no let the police
that's illegal
hahahaha
I died all right 64 wait rope
I have a skin rope to this when do I
have a rope you come with me buddy chase
us Christ stop go stop stop stop please
I'm sorry it's so annoying oh my god no
octopus Cthulhu is alive like I said
this game is no flourish wait what do I
have a car on I have a car on a rope
I have a car the rope and I'm a pigeon
how does this possible feel like the
game suffers from being too realistic it
just I can't be immersed if it's not God
stop that does happen I've seen that in
real life like I should make the action
movie at this point oh god I should
sorry
there we go we got him ladies and
gentlemen all right here we go here we
go this is for punching me earlier why I
can't fly I'm stuck
oh no this this is what breaks the game
really perfect landing all right well
this has been pigeon simulator very fun
epic game mash like subscribe if you
want the more and as always bye-bye